my name is Seth Cluett I'm the assistant
director of the sound art program at
Columbia University and I'm the curator
of "Sounding Circuits: Audible Histories"
at the Vincent Astor gallery at the New
York Public Library for the Performing
Arts at Lincoln Center. You know from the
earliest times that I started to get
interested in electronic music you
always heard about the Columbia-
Princeton Electronic Music Center and
the RCA Mark 2 Synthesizer and the work
that happened here in the 70s and 80s
around the development of new
technologies for electronic music and as
I went through my education it turned
out I got to know more and more people
associated with Columbia. Since May of
2017 I've been the artist in residence
at Bell Labs and now I'm in the position
of the Acting Director at the computer
Music Center and that kind of bookends
the two poles of early electronic and
computer music Bell Labs was a hotbed of
early research into speech synthesis and
digital signal processing and anyone who
was here at Columbia or at Princeton who
wanted to hear their sounds had to go to
Bell Labs in the 60s in order to render
them on their own the only digital to
analog converter on the East Coast. People have been amazed at the hardware
the most that these devices for one
still exist and that they still exist
here and they're in our collections and in
some case they're still in use in our
facility and that anyone could use it at
all to make music. I'm creating a series
suite of seven small works 30 seconds to
a minute long that alternate with eight
sort of 30-second to a minute long
excerpts from classic pieces of
electronic and computer music the sphere
uses a kind of audio rendering called
ambisonics which is a 360 degree audio
experience but the goal is to help
people understand how fresh these
historic works sound and help give a
context for some of the impact of those
works on my own practice and what I'm
hoping with this exhibition to show is
that these are real human beings
engaging with other real human beings
trying at a time when there are no
references no precedents to come up with
a new way of making sound
and I think Columbia and Bell Labs and
the New York Public Library are in a
very unique position to be able to show
people how vibrant those interactions
between people were